[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN: Please join me in
welcoming Mitch to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
MITCH DOBROWNER: Thanks.
Thanks.
Thanks, Martin.
And I still want to keep
this a secret just in case.
I just don't like anybody to
know I actually take pictures.
So anyway I wanted to talk a
little bit about photography,
so at least my world
of photography.
To me, the images that I
show were never really meant
to be like commercial images.
Or they really were
for me just to document
my experience of how I
saw the world, pretty much
for my family, for my children,
kind of to leave something
behind.
I don't expect to be
here another 50 years,
probably not another
20 years even,
but I wanted to leave
something behind.
A little bit about
me, even though,
I don't want to
talk a lot about me.
It's more about the work.
You know I came out
of the East coast.
I grew up there.
Pretty interesting
background, but had
nothing to do with
art or photography
or any of those aspects.
And I was introduced probably
when I was about 18--
and probably getting
into a lot of trouble--
to the work of like Ansel
Adams and Minor White.
And I had never seen anything
like that before in my life.
So my father in his
kind of way would
try to get me kind
of grounded in life,
slung me a little
rangefinder camera.
And as soon as I
picked up the camera,
I just felt like
I was electrified.
And I started to take
off and take pictures.
And being on the East
coast, for me at least,
there wasn't a
lot to photograph.
So looking at the
pictures of Ansel Adams
and starting to study his work,
I got into the wet dark room
and into film cameras, became
interested in technology.
Didn't really want to be
overwhelmed by the technology.
Or I wanted to know
enough about it,
so I started to work in
sensitometry, which was pretty
much the manufacturing of film.
So I ended up in a lab
with a bunch of scientists
with silver nitrate and
acetate and a paint brush
and a bunch of developer
and started to create film.
And then read that stuff
with a densitometer
and pretty much
understand film, which
helped me not being intimidated
by the tools that I was using.
So anyway I was also
introduced by somebody
called Pete Turner at the time.
So I ended up working with
Pete as one of his assistants.
And Pete Turner taught
me at that time just
to break all the
rules of photography,
never to follow any rules
or anything that anybody
says unless it's positive.
So he got me into
experimenting with film.
So I would experiment
taking ektachrome type film
and developing in C-41
which was for development
in negative film and just
see what those things
were like, and infrared
photography, shooting tungsten
film in daylight.
Just breaking every
rule which actually
led to a grant from Canon
Camera when I was about 20
that got me out of
New York, thank god,
and into the West coast.
So I started
traveling the country
and started to
see the landscapes
that Ansel Adams and Minor White
and Ed Weston had photographed.
And it was a bit
overwhelming to me.
Anyway did a show in
LA when I was about 21.
Met my beautiful wife.
Had a bunch of kids.
Ran a business and gave up
photography for 20 years
pretty much to raise the
family and raise my children.
And picked up a camera
again probably about 2006.
And again, I was
overwhelmed by what
I started to see when I started
looking through the camera lens
again.
A friend had took me
out to Death Valley.
And I became totally involved
with photography again.
So my journey,
this journey, here
is roughly about 10
years worth of work.
Some of the things about
photography for me are it's
really about light,
seeing light,
being able to paint with light.
A lot of the stuff in
landscape photography,
at least for me is, we
live, at least for me,
we live in somewhat of a world
that can be sometimes chaotic.
There's a lot of
sensory overload.
And when I go out to shoot
landscapes, first of all I
see in black and white.
I've always seen
in black and white.
It's an artistic
expression for me
that allows me at least to
interpret how I see the world.
But in the painting
of light, it's
almost like it's allowing
all the chaos to take form.
So even when I'm out shooting
landscape photography,
there's so many
different compositions,
so many things to shoot, it
allows me to kind of ground
myself to be able to have
everything that I'm thinking,
everything that I'm seeing,
take a certain form.
It's almost like
seeing in a dark--
walking into a dark room and
out from the bright sunshine.
And a lot of times when I go--
most of times when I go
out to these landscapes,
it takes a couple
of days for me just
to detach from life in Los
Angeles and everything else.
They're all good things.
There's nothing bad about that.
But just to get in the mode
of being a photographer
and seeing as a photographer.
So usually for the
first couple of days,
I don't really even shoot.
I might scout.
I might just try to get quiet,
try to get back into my body
again and see the world
in a much quieter place.
A place that has a certain
form, a certain peace.
It's almost like when I'm
standing outside everything--
I've said it before--
things just get quiet.
Time seems to truncate.
I can hear my heartbeat again,
which is a rare occasion.
And a peace comes over to me
and I can see in a certain way
when I take pictures.
So I've also, obviously
from some of the things
you could say have been in
my past have influenced a lot
by things like science fiction.
Some of the movies
when I was growing up
that were most
important to me were
like my favorite
movie of all time
is "King Kong," like
the 1933 version of it
and "The Wizard of Oz."
Those are the things that
influenced me visually.
So this is like 2006 going
out to Monument Valley.
I became interested
in volcanoes.
This happens to be
an ancient volcano.
What happens with some
of these structures are--
if you can imagine, I don't
know how many years ago,
10,000 years ago, that is
basically the lava core.
It was covered with dirt.
The dirt erodes
over the lava core,
eventually starts to
erode the lava core.
And I started to
become interested
in those type of structures.
Most of the times
when I'd go out,
I will go out for
weeks at a time.
I would say photographing
the landscape
for me is kind of like
photographing a person.
When I'm out there, I never
really take a snapshot.
I know when I
first get out there
I'm wasting my time if
I'm just shooting away.
I like to usually go out
alone, so it's really quiet.
But I like to understand
the landscape a little bit,
understand it like
if I was shooting
a portrait of a person.
I wouldn't just not know you,
say hello, take a picture
and think I was a
great photographer.
Maybe there are
great photographers
and Leigh Woods of the world.
I don't even think
she does that.
But I like to stay there for
a while just quietly looking
around, watching
the light, looking
at the different
compositions until I
can kind of
understand my subject
and understand
what the light is.
I always love to go out
in inclement weather.
That's when I see light
being the most interesting
to me, also low
contrast situations.
Though as a photographer,
it's really interesting
to shoot in all different
types of situations.
It kind of allows you to
expand your abilities just
to say this is what
it's giving me.
How can I create an image?
What am I feeling?
If I don't get
into that feeling I
know I'm kind of
wasting my time.
It's almost like getting into
a zone like a basketball player
or something when
they get into a zone.
I have to take the time
to get into a certain zone
to be able to take pictures.
There's also things--
this is an interesting one
because this is Shiprock.
It's also a spiritual
center of the Navajos.
So going out to Farmington, I
went out there with my family,
with my wife and my son.
We were out there,
I think for 10 days.
And there was something
kind of special about this,
something special to be--
I've spent a lot of
time in southern Utah
and so forth with
the American Indians
and especially
with the Navajos--
and there was something
extremely special
about this rock.
And I actually had
seen this picture.
A lot of times
before I go out, I'll
do research and/or I'll see a
picture in my head of exactly
what I wanted to photograph.
And in this case, when I saw
the initial pictures of Shiprock
in my head, I always
saw a rock in motion,
that it wasn't just a rock.
But it was in a live rock.
But what happened is I was out
there, I think for 10 days,
and never got a picture
that I really liked.
I never got like into that zone.
And I was a little frustrated.
And I think it was the
eighth day, it was cold out.
It was probably 10 degrees out.
I got up at 4:00 in the morning.
It was about 50 mile ride from
Farmington out to Shiprock.
Rock
And as I got up, I was
like you're an idiot.
What are you getting up for?
You stay in bed
with your family.
You'll be cozy.
You're not get any pictures.
Everything's running through
my brain, like what an idiot.
You know?
So I got into my truck.
And I'm driving out there
with a cup of coffee.
And the whole time it's
like it's getting dark,
it's like nothing,
what am I doing?
Wasting my time again.
And I got out there.
And I had scouted this location.
When I got out there,
there was the cloud cover
had dropped below Shiprock.
And you could not see Shiprock.
And I stood out there, I think
for about six hours, just
waiting.
And it was a real spiritual
experience for me.
This is a real special picture
for me, because this is both--
this is the picture
I had seen in my head
when I was out there.
Besides that, what
it represented to
me is just tenacity.
That, at least for me,
that if you kind of believe
in your abilities, you're
tenacious about stuff,
and you just don't give up,
you will get what you want.
You don't always, you know?
But this represented
a lot to me.
This is a foundational
picture for me.
This is another kind of
foundational picture for me.
This is the Maze.
This is the border of the
Maze and the Needles District
in Canyonlands.
The Maze is probably the
area of the United States
which is probably one of the
hardest areas to get into.
So I'm lucky enough to
be a National Geographic
photographer.
I have no idea
how that happened.
But they contacted me
and published my work
and put me up on their sites.
So I hired an outfitting
group out of Moab.
And we took 10
days into the Maze.
And this is like the kind of
area where if you travel--
and not exaggerating--
like 10 miles
will take you probably 12 hours.
There's no roads there.
You're rock climbing
the whole way.
And again I'm out there for
10-- this is the 10th day.
And I was a wreck.
I mean I had not taken a
bath or shower or anything,
cleaned up in 10 days.
My hair was like dreadlocks.
I just wanted to go home.
I was exhausted.
And the guy I was with was like,
hey, one more time, you know.
Let's go out.
I have this one place.
We have to get out there like
3:00, 4:00 in the morning.
We have to climb this 1,000
foot mesa in the dark.
And I got this one shot
I want to show you.
Nobody really knows about it.
And I'm like, no, I
don't want to do this.
But I say god damn it--
excuse my language--
but god damn it, let's do it.
So I went up there and
this was the shot I got.
Which for me was kind
of a culmination of what
I had seen for the Needles
District in Canyonlands.
I had been there
a couple of times.
But I had never
got the one picture
that represented that for me.
Another area, White Pocket.
I took five days out
into White Pocket.
Have no idea how
this was formed.
But obviously it was
under water at some time.
There's actually dinosaur
tracks out a White Pocket.
In the background it's
something called Brain Rock
which actually looks like Brain
Rock, a really interesting
area.
But what I'm trying
to do here is just
take portraits of the things
that I'm experiencing,
the places that I go.
This is Superstition
Mountain in Arizona.
We were out there for-- this
one was like four or five days.
I waited four or five
days for that little cloud
to go overhead because it
was just bright sunlight.
But it took five days to
wait in that certain area
just to get that picture.
But again, this is
another ancient volcano.
This is Capitol Reef.
Me and my son went out there.
This is standing on a 2,000 foot
mesa overlooking the valley.
Anyway, something I shot
a couple of weeks ago.
It's actually a
reshoot or something
I was at out in Lone Pine.
But to me, these images
speak something to me.
Each one to me is
like a little child.
And I think even
there was a quote
that I read from I think
it was Renoir who--
I'm just going to read it
because I wrote it down.
And it says, "At the
start of seeing a subject,
you're always in
a sort of a haze.
But you know perfectly that
what you should see later
has been there all the time."
And the same thing
for Monument Valley.
Monument Valley's always been--
it's been photographed
so many times.
But I had always
see the picture that
was a little bit different
of Monument Valley.
So again I went up there
with a Navajo guide.
And we took four days out there.
And I learned a lot about the
Navajo culture at the time.
And really wanted to take a
portrait of Monument Valley
that represented
not so much to me
what the valley was
about, but to the Navajos
what the valley was about.
What it might have looked
like when they first
took a look at it.
Also a shot of Monument Valley.
So I'm just going
to go through these.
All these pictures
basically to me
speak a special
moment to me in time.
Landscapes are really
interesting for me to shoot.
Actually we'll get to some of
the storm images, which people
seem to be interested in.
I actually take
it, as an artist--
that I don't even know if I'm
an artist, but if I am one--
that the images are
really just shot for me.
I feel really lucky that people
actually just like the images.
One thing about these
images, though--
and you can see that
out in the lobby--
is that I'll talk a little
bit about the technologies
in a moment.
But that for me
these are just JPEGs.
These are proxies of
the final final images.
But the print is really
what my final image
is, the final vision
for my work is.
So everything I'm
doing, every way
I'm shooting, everything
about the capture
and is about what I'm
going to do for a print.
So if you do have time, you
can go out later into the lobby
and take a look at
some of the prints.
This was a reflection of me.
This is Agathla Peak,
which is the center,
the graphical center
of the Navajo Nation.
But what this represented
to me when I saw
it was "The Wizard of Oz."
This is like the
Wicked Witch's castle.
You know?
And I always kind of see those
things when I'm photographing.
This another picture.
This is the Doll House.
This is out in the
Needles District again.
But to me this is
almost something
like out of "The Wizard of Oz."
Some of these places
are extremely remote.
This is the Maze.
The kind of place where
it's really fun to be in,
but you also get--
I think there's some kind of--
I don't know what
people call it.
When you're in a
super remote location,
and there's like nobody
around like 20 miles around
except maybe the person
that you're with.
And things start to really
get close and truncated
and you feel like if you're
going to break an ankle,
you're just going
to die out there.
So a lot of these
locations were like that.
This is Trona.
I don't know if
anybody knows where
Trona is, the Trona Pinnacles.
It's a really outrageous
beautiful place.
It's where I love to
practice photography.
Actually this is
an area that Apollo
used to practice their moonwalks
before they went to the moon.
So most one of the areas
in California that's most
like the surface of the moon.
But I was lucky enough to be out
there in like-- at that point--
50 mile an hour winds and
catch a lenticular cloud
on top of the Pinnacles.
Another shot of Trona
at a different time.
This is driving through
a dry lake bed with water
up to the middle to
the top of my wheels
in my four-wheel
drive truck just
to get up to the Pinnacles.
This is almost an omen to
one of the Ansel Adam shots,
the Hernandez shot.
And just in full
landscape photography.
Every one from me has a story.
This is Goblin Valley.
But at this point, I was covered
with gnats from head to toe.
Everything that was
not covered was bit.
You know?
And I was covered.
I had gloves.
I had everything.
My ears were just red.
But I was like I am going to
get the picture that I want.
I had to wait there covered with
gnats for a little while, just
to get that picture.
I had to wait for the
light to be right.
Mexican Hat.
Meanwhile I've
camped out in Trona
at this time I have
no idea what that was.
I've heard it was just
a rare occurrence.
This is the light, the sun
was actually rising behind me.
Maybe it was the
dust in the air.
But it was really interesting
for National Geographic where
they publish all my work, which
was actually the storm work.
When they took a
look at the work,
a lot of people when I get
into fine art photography,
thought that a lot of this
was manipulated images.
And they're actually not.
National Geographic
had taken, at the time,
some of my raw files
and my 16-bit tiffs
and taken them to their
lab just to make sure they
weren't even graded too much.
And I'll talk a little
bit about the technology.
This one is a meteor
about to hit the Earth.
When it happens, that picture.
This is actually
a piece of rock,
a piece of ice in Iceland.
Some people have
looked at that and said
they could not get a grasp
of exactly what that was.
Iceland is cold.
And I was out there in March.
But it was beautiful.
Another shot of Iceland.
And this is a time where--
I don't mean to be
overly dramatic with it,
but it was so cold out there
that anything that was exposed
froze.
You don't usually get those
kind of clouds on a mountain
scape unless you're
standing in the wind.
And the ocean is
to your right here.
And the winds were just
coming off the ocean
with nothing blocking them.
And my hardest problem
was breathing into a mask
and having my glasses
just turn to ice.
So I had to figure out
how to photograph that.
One of my lucky
snapshots of this lake.
This one was interesting.
This is Joshua Tree.
This one represented like a
rock family to me, you know?
This is like the dad's in
the middle with the eye.
The uncle's over
there on the left.
The aunt's on the right.
And the punk kid
with the spiky hair
is kind of standing
in the middle.
And it's just standing there
in a portrait, you know,
a proud portrait.
And also just something
that was real simple to me.
It was just like the basic use
of light and shadow and tone.
It was just a very
simple photograph to me.
But I really like
this photograph
because of its simplicity.
It's just forms and light.
I'll get into another story.
These stories are just
interesting to me.
This is me my son
going off to Escalante.
He'll remember that.
He's here.
And we spent like a week
out there in December.
Came through, nothing.
I had no pictures.
I froze.
We were going through the snow.
No.
I've got some good pictures but
nothing that I really liked.
And as we were driving home, we
went through the Virgin River
Gorge and through a snowstorm.
And as we came
out the other end,
we like had to take a break.
We had to actually
use the bathroom.
So we just got out.
We said before we hit Las Vegas,
let's just take one last break.
And we'll just bolt home.
And I took my camera with me.
My son, we went off hiking
in different directions.
And I heard my son just
say, dad, dad, come here.
You know?
I came over the ridge.
And this was the picture.
So I was out there for a week,
maybe a little bit longer
than a week.
Got nothing that I liked.
And this is I think one
of the last three pictures
I shot off the trip.
Which again to me showed
that you just never know.
You never know.
If you just stay
tenacious and still
believe that you could actually
accomplish those things.
Then I got into storm chasing,
because I always went out
into inclement weather.
And I thought that it would
be really interesting to see
what Tornado Alley was like.
So this is a picture
that came later in my--
I'm not a storm chaser
and a photographer.
I go out with a friend
who's a storm chaser.
He's brilliant.
His name's Roger Hill.
And this is like I always
saw in the series of pictures
that I was taking that I needed
an iconic tornado picture.
And this was kind of
like a reflection to me,
again, of "The Wizard of Oz."
In fact, I worked
at Sony for a while,
Sam Raimi had done a
remake of "Wizard of Oz."
And the visual effects
supervisor had said, hey,
we heard--
we were in a room.
We're looking at all this--
you know we're doing some
research on like tornadoes
for the sequence.
And we saw this picture.
And then somebody in
the room said, hey,
you know that guy works here?
You know.
So anyway so I had to
make a big print for them.
And they used this for
some of their research
on the tornado sequence.
But anyway, this is a really
easy picture to shoot.
We were like a mile and
a half from the tornado.
It was moving east to west.
It was quiet.
And I could take my
time and compose.
And again this is
another picture
that I actually
had seen in my mind
before I had gone out there.
This is last year.
So a little bit about storm
chasing or about photographing
the storm systems.
I had never seen anything
like this in my life.
These are real pictures.
These are like real situations.
But coming from the East
coast and going out there
and seeing this--
they're just awe inspiring.
There's no way to actually--
these pictures don't
even do justice
to what these storm
systems really are.
A lot of the challenge for me
initially for storm systems,
I was set up as a
landscape photographer.
And a lot of the
equipment was using
was not ready for
landscape photography.
So I had to adapt the first
couple of years, the way
that I was shooting.
But compositions are
constantly changing.
Light's constantly changing.
There's chaos going off
around all around you.
You have to focus.
The only thing that I listen
to when I'm out photographing
storms now was
Roger's voice saying
like we have to get the hell
out of here like right now.
You know?
And that's the only
thing I listen to.
Because everything else I
just have to really focus
and get again into that
zone for photography.
It's really helped me
improve as a photographer.
And the one thing I can
say about photography
for me is I really do think
that my best images are still
to come.
There was a semi-famous
photographer--
or at least he
thinks he's famous--
who I actually met at one
point when I first started.
And he was he was talking
to me and telling me
about how his images look
the same from 1979 into--
I think at the time
it was like 2007.
How all the transitions
are the same,
how the pictures look the same,
the compositions look the same.
And I kind of looked at him and
I said, well, have you changed?
I mean how could your
photographies be the same?
Have you grown in 25, 30 years?
And I looked over
at his wife who
actually kicked
me under the table
and smiled at me
when I said that.
Because I did not understand
like how as a photographer
your images either
can't get better or how
as you grow as a
person, as you mature,
that the visions that you
have and your experiences
should be reflected
in your work.
This was kind of interesting.
I don't think Lorraine
was with me on this one.
I think ABC News is
with us in this one.
And they thought
it was really fun
to be out there chasing storms.
And they got out
there and they're
playing around
with their cameras
and stuff out in the field.
And this thing turned the
corner and came at us.
And they got
destroyed, the cameras.
This was a huge hailstorm.
It actually did a lot
of damage in Moorcroft.
This is Wyoming.
The interesting picture about
that had happened to me,
though, is that
that little house
on the bottom right,
somehow my work
got into published by
the Audubon Society.
And the "Audubon" magazine
made it to the beauty parlor
in Moorcroft,
population of maybe 200.
And actually the grandson--
that somehow the
grandson saw that picture
and actually emailed
me and said, you know,
how did you get there
during that storm?
Can I have some pictures for
my grandma whose house that is?
And again, it showed me what
a small world we live in.
That this was a
pretty amazing storm.
This was the first trip out.
And when I turned to
Roger, I was like, Roger,
are we going to die?
And he was like,
don't worry about it.
We'll be fine.
This thing is
actually dissipating
as it's coming down.
But these images all mean
something special to me.
You know?
Me and my wife and my son went
out to Los Alamos one year.
And that summer I went out
and shot the monsoons out
in Arizona and came
back with this.
And it was just
that visualization
of like an experience
that I had in my life
of seeing kind of the
amazing stuff that actually,
the history of Los
Alamos that went
on with the nuclear weapons and
all that interesting history
that I really didn't
know much about.
My wife was mad at because
she was trying to paint
atomic explosions at the time.
So I came back with this.
But I had never experienced
the monsoons before.
Mammatus clouds.
The aftereffect of a
pretty violent storm.
This was a ghost.
This is in the dark.
I saw this thing.
This is like the monster in
the closet type thing for me
where the storm is
out in the field.
I could see it every time
the lightning flashed.
So I just had to do the
best to focus and compose.
Some of the really interesting
things about photography
is you can get out to
some of these locations
and you can just blow it.
You can blow your
exposure, your focus.
You have like one
shot at this stuff.
This was a rare.
This is a landspout.
This thing was gigantic.
I think this was about--
they were saying this is
about 2,000 to 3,000 feet up.
It's like if you
look at the bottom,
you can see some light poles.
I mean some electric
poles on the bottom there
that give this thing scale.
So I'm just trying to
show with these images
my experience of being
out there seeing some
of these amazing phenomenons.
This storm to me--
this looks like "War of the
Worlds" to me for some reason.
But the experience
to me of these storms
is that what's really
interesting is when
you see these storms
and they're created,
they have to be created when
the environment's right.
Humidity, the airflow,
all these things
have to take place
at the right time.
It's almost like the
birth of a person.
And when all these
elements come together,
eventually they start to form.
And they get
unpredictable, initially.
And sometimes
they'll die quickly.
And sometimes they'll take off.
And sometimes they'll
get super violent.
And then essentially they
start to take a form.
They start to form into
something that has structure.
And eventually they will
start to lose that form.
And they age out
and they just die.
So as I'm photographing
these storms,
they're actually like
living beings things to me.
And I'm just trying
to capture, I'm
just trying to do justice
to each one of these storms.
Because they'll never be again.
Like these structures, these
storms, these pictures,
I don't have to worry
about another photographer
copying these images.
They can shoot
storms all they want.
But these storms are once
in a lifetime type events.
And they're just phenomenal.
So all I'm trying to do here
is to do justice to this.
I love the play of light and
dark and things like this.
This was a pretty
amazing lightning storm.
Lots of people use
different techniques
for shooting lightning.
I don't use a lightning trigger.
I just use long
exposures and luck.
It's the luck of the draw.
But I feel like I need to.
That's the way that
I want to shoot.
I want it to be as
natural as I possibly
can be with these photographs.
And I'll talk a little
bit about light.
This is the second time I
ever did sort of a storm.
This was in Nebraska.
And this thing was
probably, maybe
according to some people, the
most violent storm of the year.
Why it's so white
on the bottom is
there was a long exposure and
multiple lightning strikes.
It's a mesocyclone basically.
So now I'll talk a little
bit about the technology
and the printing and how--
before I run out of time--
how I get to this.
Pretty much going
back to Pete Turner
and breaking all the rules, when
you shot black and white film
in the day, you used to
load black and white film.
Shot color film,
you use color film.
Today with digital technology,
digital cameras, most--
today at least-- digital
cameras in black and white
are extremely expensive.
But the sensors, the
black and white sensors,
they're naturally
black and white.
What happens is for the
camera manufacturers
to build these cameras, they
need to emulate how we see.
So we see, as far as
light waves are concerned,
about between 400 and
700 nanometers of light.
That's how we see.
So when you see there's a
sensor on top of the sensor
go to a Bayer pattern.
And the Bayer pattern
goes over each pixel.
It's filters basically-- two
green, one red, one blue.
That's because our eyes see
more green than red than blue.
So they try to emulate
the way that our eyes see.
They also truncate light.
So the sensors can see-- even
though we see from 400 to 700
nanometers of light--
sensors can see between
roughly 300 nanometers
to about 1,100
nanometers of light.
So I don't believe
in that stuff.
So I can't take the
Bayer patterns off,
even though I've tried.
There's a gentleman
out in New Jersey.
And we've blown up
a lot of sensors
doing this trying to take
the Bayer patterns off.
But I do take off
anti-aliasing filters,
which are only made
so there's no more
array when you take pictures.
I've done this for 10 years now.
It's a big, big deal.
They think that camera's
sell for more money
when they take those off.
I also take off the
IR blocking filters.
And in black and
white that allows
me to see in the infrared,
ultraviolet, things
that you can't see
with your natural eye.
It also allows me then to--
the way that I filter is
based on the environment
and what I'm looking at.
It allows me to use my
camera as a paintbrush now.
Now I can filter
based on what I'm
shooting, what the
light looks like, what
the environment looks like.
It just allows me to use
my camera as a brush.
I'm not somebody who
shines his cameras up.
I usually throw my camera out.
I trash my cameras.
My lenses are more
important than my cameras.
But my cameras are
basically a brush.
If I was a painter, it
would be my paintbrush.
So I filter, basically,
with screw on lenses,
screw on filters on the
lenses, how I would want to.
I actually had worked with Sony.
Somehow I won-- it's
another story-- photographer
of the year for Sony.
And they made a
big deal out of it.
And one of the first
cameras they shot
was an R1, which was
a mirrorless camera.
And it made sense for Sony
because Sony had always
invented video cameras which
never had mirrors on it.
So when I was talking
to Sony at the time,
it was like they
discontinued the camera
and I wasn't happy about
that, because I always
felt like having a mirror
box in and a camera
was kind of old school thinking.
So light's coming
through the lens.
It's bouncing over
a bunch of mirrors
and going through
the viewfinder.
But you can never see what
you're actually shooting with,
what you're actually shooting.
It was great for
sports photography,
because it allows
you to focus quickly.
But for landscape
photography, I use the LCD.
So I use the live
view on the cameras.
So now when I filter with
like things like an IR lens,
IR filter, which is the opaque.
So when you shot with that in
film, you have to look at it.
You screw on the filter.
And you could not see
what you were shooting.
But now I can actually see
what the sensor's seeing.
I can see the direct
feed off the sensor.
So anyway that is
like one of the ways
that I've adapted my
shooting, my cameras.
Also there's a lot of
techniques as far as printing.
Again everything's important.
As far as the print's
concerned, there
is a lot of literature
on the right way
to shoot with the sensor.
If you think of a sensor, you
usually see things like noise
in the shadows, that's because
that part of the sensor
pretty much inputs
the least amount,
the highlights are what has
the most amount of data.
If you shoot with your
histogram to the right,
you're moving your shadows
into a more sweet spot
on the sensor.
And you're getting
a cleaner image
basically when you do a print.
So I think all these things,
when it comes down to a print,
makes a big difference.
Also with printing, the more
that you manipulate an image,
the more data you throw away.
When you're in something like
Photoshop, which is my editor,
every time you
turning the slider,
you're throwing data away.
So if you took like a 8 bit JPEG
and you kind of move sliders
around in Photoshop and took
a look at your histogram,
it looks like a tooth comb.
That's because you've
thrown away all that data.
So now I'm working
with raw files--
and I think Ansel Adams
always said that pretty much
the original capture for
him, the film negative, kind
of represented, the
beginning of the journey.
But the symphony, the
way it was orchestrated,
was really the way
the print was made.
PAUL: The score of
the performance.
MITCH DOBROWNER: The
score of the performance.
Thank you, Paul.
So really I'm going towards
the performance with this.
But I do need to have the
foundation of the data
structure to be correct.
This is a little
diffused because I was
standing in the pouring rain.
But it was quite a sight.
Thin printing is a
whole different level.
I've probably spent
tens of thousands
of dollars throwing away
papers and inks and printers
and experimenting.
People think that
digital printing--
I came from the wet darkroom.
So I came from originally
the cold light.
I shot with four
by fives and eight
by tens cold light
printing, sensitometry.
When I moved into the
digital dark room,
it was completely different.
But it was just as complex.
So to come out with a
digital museum quality print
was just as challenging
as doing silver printing.
Over time, it's taken time to
be able to do all my own prints.
But it's taken time
and energy to be
able to kind of perfect
the printing process, just
like a printer of silver prints.
This is interesting.
This was this was a triptych.
A different story with my
youngest son which was like--
this is going back to
family a little bit.
But I asked my son
to come out with me
storm chasing,
because I wanted him
to have an experience
with his dad
that he'd remember for
the rest of his life.
So I wanted to have
a picture of him
standing in front of a tornado.
And he was like,
yeah, dad, right.
Anyway, I don't have
the picture here.
But we were standing
in Nebraska and had
experienced twin tornadoes,
Pilger, Nebraska.
And actually my
son took a selfie
of himself standing in
front of those tornadoes.
And he swears he
didn't say, dad,
can we get out of here now?
But I remember him
saying that to me.
I thought you were kidding.
But this was a triptych.
This is actually hanging in the
National Weather Center now.
They have purchased this.
It's something that they thought
was both scientific to them,
they had never seen
something like this
like in stills at that quality,
and also somewhat artistic,
if you want to call it that.
Just scale.
This was just a beautiful scene.
Everybody was shooting in
this direction I was with.
And I looked in that direction.
I'm going to go a
little bit faster here.
That's that same tornado
that the triptych
was in a different moment.
Then Los Angeles.
I don't want to
run too far over.
But I think Los
Angeles is beautiful.
I know a lot of people
don't think that.
I wouldn't live here
if I didn't think that.
So I came from the East coast.
When I came over the 405 and
I saw the San Fernando Valley,
I thought it looked
like Yosemite Valley.
I thought it was the
most beautiful thing
I had ever seen in my life.
I know where I was.
I pulled off the freeway
at Roscoe Boulevard.
I made a right.
I saw a place for rent.
And I moved in there.
I didn't know where
the hell I was.
I had no idea where I was.
But I had to go back like--
I don't know how many
years later, 30 years later
maybe, 25 years
later-- and capture
that shot of what I felt like
when I first saw Los Angeles.
So people like Paul
were really mad at me.
Paul represents me in
Los Angeles at a gallery,
because I didn't
know what I was doing
when I started in photography
and like fine art photography.
The one thing I can
say is that I've always
concentrated on the pictures.
I don't want to be famous.
I don't fame.
I don't care about all
that stuff, that ego, I
have to drop all that stuff.
I just concentrate
on the pictures.
But everything that
came to me that I
realized in my photography
actually came to me.
Like Paul called me.
I don't know.
I never called
you, I don't think.
I have a book by Aperture,
two by 21st Editions.
I think I have a show
in Dubai right now.
Everything came to me.
And the thing that to exhort
anybody about that with
is I just focused
on the pictures.
I just wanted to
take good pictures.
It was my art.
It was really important to me.
It was spiritual to me.
It was like everything
that I'm about is
reflected in these pictures.
People talk a talk.
And people are really nice.
I love people.
But it's not about that.
It's about this kind of
work, it reflects me.
And the other photographers
that are out there in the world,
those pictures reflect them.
And the pictures that you
would take reflect you.
And I think that it's
important to be able to drop--
for me it was important to
drop a lot of what was worldly
about the world
when I take pictures
and just focus on this quiet
place that I can get into.
The City of LA
actually came to me--
I don't know how they
came to me and found me,
but they commissioned
installations
in the metro systems because
they had never really seen
people take pictures of LA that
made LA look good, you know.
[LAUGHTER]
So these are some
of the pictures.
This is my experience
of Los Angeles.
This is how I feel about LA.
You know?
And I actually do love the city.
I think it's beautiful.
If I could, I wish I
could live 500 years
and watch-- people
they buy a house
and they think they own it.
But in reality,
you don't own that.
You're borrowing it.
If I could take a picture
of this in 500 years,
you'd see the
buildings come and go
and come and go and build
and decay and come and go.
But the landscape would
say pretty much the same,
unless we get a large
earthquake or something.
You know?
But otherwise, the
land is precious.
And I think I'm just trying
to reflect that in the city.
So I just think that
I'm pretty honored
to be at Google talking
about this stuff,
because I think Google
is doing some things now
that are both I would
say revolutionary.
But also I think when it
comes to the work that's truly
being done, I think
it, for mankind, it's
more actually evolutionary.
I think that we're actually
evolving now into--
this is in my opinion, I just
think we're still somewhat
in the dark ages of technology.
I think it's just starting
to accelerate now.
50 or 100 years from now who
knows what will take place.
But I do think that I'm
just honored to be here.
So thank you for inviting me.
Martin, thank you.
Thank you, Ben.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
I certainly want to
leave time for questions.
AUDIENCE: Give
Michael a new mic.
MITCH DOBROWNER: OK.
AUDIENCE: So Mitch,
I know you've worked
a long time in visual effects.
So what is your opinion
now on the ethics
of modifying the picture
after you've taken it?
Because you could
probably save yourself
a lot of time
waiting for the light
if you just changed
the lighting.
MITCH DOBROWNER: Yeah.
No, I would just say that
I don't have any judgment
about anybody who does that.
Knock yourself out.
It's just not the way that
I want to conduct myself.
To me this is what I do, this
is the way I want to do it.
I was talking to Ben earlier
and just saying even with prints
when I see prints of
all the photographers.
And I've bought
a couple of them.
And I don't look at a
lot of other photography.
I try to stay in
my little vacuum.
It's a journey to me.
The whole idea of planning
to go to a location,
to go to a location to
actually shooting a shot,
to editing the
shot on a computer,
to seeing the first
prints come out,
to seeing somebody like a
gallery or somebody saying,
hey, we'd like a print of that,
seeing somebody buy the print.
When that happens, I don't even
let my anybody pack the prints.
I usually cut the tape.
And I bring it to FedEx.
And it's a journey.
And I have to kind of
complete that journey.
But that's just me.
So nothing about
manipulating images.
Knock yourself out.
It's just not what I want to do.
AUDIENCE: What
about transparency.
Like no one asks--
no one thinks they have a right
to ask the photographer how
they got the shot
before the shot.
But most people seem
to want transparency
in exactly how it was
modified after the fact.
Do you see any essential
distinction there
or is it all just part
of the artistic process?
MITCH DOBROWNER: I
think it's all part
of the artistic journey.
And for me, it was just like
there's a couple of things
that I was happy about
in my journey, which
was like somebody like
National Geographic certifying
that the pictures
weren't heavily modified
and actually having some
museums collect my prints.
Which to me it wasn't about
a museum collecting my print
because I was so good and
great and all that stuff,
it was just that I had
reached a place with my art
that somebody
thought that it would
go into a collection
for a long time
and maybe be a little bit more
eternal than just temporal.
So and the books were
really important to me.
The print, I don't
know what's going
on with print in the future.
You know?
Everything that's going
on in the internet now,
I was really happy
about the books,
because I think the print
is, to me, is my end product.
It's amazingly valuable to
look at something like that.
I highly respect
all the other ways
that media is being
interpreted now.
But to me, it was just
the way I was in my DNA
that the print was
my final product.
You know?
So.
The bathroom is over--
AUDIENCE: I know
this is probably not
going to be one of the best
questions you ever heard.
In fact, it's--
MITCH DOBROWNER:
Probably the best one
AUDIENCE: --probably
pretty classic.
What's your favorite
picture that you've
taken and, well, why?
MITCH DOBROWNER: That's
a really good question.
My favorite picture I've
taken is the Shiprock picture,
because it meant the most to me.
In fact, I have it
tattooed on my arm.
That's how much it meant to me.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
MITCH DOBROWNER: And
that's just because when
I go through my days--
it's kind of like a
quarterback in a football,
if you watch football.
Sometimes they just have to
look down at the plays going on.
I just need to be
inspired sometimes.
And that picture just inspired
me, not so much the picture,
but the experience
of capturing it.
AUDIENCE: How did the
experience inspire
you to do what you
exactly I mean to become
a better photographer or what?
MITCH DOBROWNER: Yeah.
It taught me about believing
in myself a little bit more.
That when all those things
were going through my mind
that I couldn't do
something that I just put
my head down and
kept on doing it
even though that
voice on my shoulder
was saying that
I couldn't do it.
And I ended up doing it.
I don't think it
was an accident.
So I think what happens
is that maybe there's
a photography god that says
when I've spilled enough sweat
and blood on a
landscape photography,
they'll open up and
show me what I came for.
I truly believe that.
Sometimes I think
that you really
just need to put your
head down and persevere
through something.
And I drove 1,200 miles for
that picture, just one picture.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, Mitch.
MITCH DOBROWNER: Thank you.
Those were great
questions by the way.
AUDIENCE: I love the
stories about how
you sort of track down the
pictures that you want.
I was wondering
what's the longest
time you've spent between coming
up with an idea for a picture
that you wanted and getting
the shot you wanted?
MITCH DOBROWNER:
Right now, probably.
So for me in my
personal life, I've
been working like Dan had
said in like visual effects
and technology for, I
don't know, 25 years,
and decided that I had--
I'm going to call it it's
really interesting work.
But it was just time
for me to chase my dream
and get back into my photography
and get into what was
important for me for my life.
I think life is super short.
We're not here very long,
even if you live to be 100,
it's just a drop in the bucket.
I don't even know my great,
great, great grandfather's
name.
They existed.
They had rougher
lives than I've had.
But I've decided like
over the past four months
that I need to get
back into that zone.
So the world that
I was in before
had basically sucked my
creativity out of me.
And it was just time to move on.
So some of the pictures that
I showed from the Lone Pine,
by accident, those--
actually I wasn't
really there to shoot pictures.
It was more like just to start
to get back into that zone--
were some of the beginnings of
just this next journey that I'm
going to take on.
And like I said before, I
think you do grow as a person.
And as you grow into
a person things--
I hope that my images evolve.
And I always have thought
that my best images will come,
that I'm not done.
This is just probably the
middle of my journey right now.
Hope that answered the question.
So right now I'm
getting back into it
after about a three month break.
MARTIN: Are there
any more questions?
AUDIENCE: I really
enjoyed your talk.
I liked the way how
you explained your work
through light and spirituality.
I assume the Los Angeles
work is your newest work?
MITCH DOBROWNER: Is what?
AUDIENCE: Your newest or--
MITCH DOBROWNER: No,
it's not, actually.
It's some of my older work.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
MITCH DOBROWNER:
Yeah, the one that--
I never finished the
story about Paul,
like that first shot which I
labeled like civilization--
I'll back it up a couple--
this shot.
I think I shot that in 2006.
And why the
galleries didn't like
it is that I did
an edition of 100.
And the galleries are like you
can't do an edition of 100,
you're edition of 5.
You sell it at like
a zillion dollars.
And 100, how are
we going to sell?
So that edition's at
like 92 of 100 now.
So they're wrong.
They were wrong.
[LAUGHTER]
So anyway, because people
related somehow to that image.
I mean when I first
showed it to some friends,
they were like, oh nice.
And they were like wait a
second, those buildings?
I thought they were just
trees and mountains?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
When you look at this
image, you could kind of
blend it into your
landscape photography
and out of a sudden, gosh,
there is a skyscraper
or kind of a house.
So but the difference between
the landscape photography
or the natural
landscape photography
and the urban landscape
photography you do here
is that I think you
photograph from the ground
in the landscape but here
you have this overview right?
MITCH DOBROWNER: Right.
AUDIENCE: So I'm wondering
is it from a helicopter
or always from skyscrapers?
MITCH DOBROWNER: It's
from Mulholland Drive.
AUDIENCE: Mulholland?
All of them?
MITCH DOBROWNER: And we only
live five minutes from there.
So it's really easy
for me to get to.
And a lot of times when
I was photographing LA--
just the honest truth, not this,
but some of the other ones--
is that I couldn't get out
into the Southwest and to Utah.
Or I couldn't get out.
It wasn't storm season.
I just was itching to
get out and photograph.
So I just grabbed the
camera on a stormy day
and just run up the
hill and just see
if I see something of the
city that I really love.
So yeah.
So a lot of these were
just because like I
was itching to shoot and I
couldn't get out of town.
And it was just time.
And the city is really to me
beautiful during the rains,
during the rainy season.
AUDIENCE: I know.
Thank you.
MITCH DOBROWNER: OK.
BLAIR: Hi, Mitch.
MITCH DOBROWNER: Hi, Blair.
BLAIR: What did you mean by
when you said you got out
to practice shooting?
MITCH DOBROWNER: Well
I think sometimes--
like now if there's a break.
Let's say I've had a couple
month break between shooting.
Say a basketball player,
and the finals are tonight.
I'm sure LeBron
practiced this week
before he's getting
ready to shoot
or he's getting ready to play.
So with photography, for
me, it's the same thing.
I have to kind of warm up.
I have to get into that mode.
It's almost meditative to me.
So during the day,
it could be chaotic.
There's things going on.
I got to go food shopping.
I've got to do something,
go walk the dog,
and all this other stuff.
That's fun, actually
walking the dog.
But I have to get
into that mode.
I have to feel that mode again.
And sometimes I can't remember
what that mode feels like.
So I know when I go out Trona--
which I actually haven't been
out to in a little while.
But I'm going to plan on
going there as soon as we get
the next change in weather--
that I can get quickly
into that zone there.
There's nobody out there.
There's no people there.
It's quiet.
It looks like another
planet out there.
And it just allows
me to kind of get
into that zone of photography to
see like a photographer again.
Usually what I do to
start to actually practice
for that is when I walk around,
I start to look at compositions
and practice being
a photographer,
even though I don't
have a camera with me.
So that's what I
meant by practice
is just to start
to kind of practice
dribbling a basketball, practice
you know swinging the bat, just
practice getting back
into that quiet place
where I can kind of
feel myself get grounded
and ready to photograph.
MARTIN: Could we thank
our speaker one more time?
MITCH DOBROWNER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]